et maintenant je reçois madame Miss
France Geneviève de Fontenay et son fils
Xavier qui visiblement ne sont pas tout
à fait d'accord surtout
bonsoir bonsoir Mireille
alors vous avez exceptionnellement
accepté d'être ensemble sur une tribune
je vous en remercie ça me va droit au
coeur alors on peut avoir confiance en
vous ça c'est énorme MERCI alors moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est qu'il y a quelques
années vous disiez tout va bien tout va
bien ils exagèrent ces journalistes on
s'entend très bien avec Xavier mon fils
et dans le livre que Xavier vous publiez
ces jours-ci l'histoire chez Flammarion
merci elle fait bien la promo
donc l'histoire secrète des Miss France
chez Flammarion vous écrivez au sujet de
votre collaboration avec votre mère
Geneviève qui a duré quand même 25 ans
aujourd'hui voilà mais dans ses rapports
avec moi
ma mère pris systématiquement le
contre-pied de ce que je pouvais dire ou
faire mais non et c'est là où je suis
pas d'accord quand je dis libre parce
que je lui disais encore dans la voiture
on arrive non je m'écoute tu racontes
plein de choses que je savais même pas
j'ai l'empêchais pas du tout de faire ce
qu'il faisait et parce que d'abord
j'ignorais et qu'il a eu la liberté
totale d'action dans tout ce qu'il a
fait et je m'aperçois qu'il avait fait
énormément de choses ils me disait pas
non mais je ne suis pas d'accord avec
ton pas d'accord
non mais vous allez vous expliquer vous
êtes là
dans le dans l'ouvrage j'empoing
métaphore bon je dis que nous étions
tous les deux dans un bateau dans une
barque et moi je rame je rame à
contre-courant parce que la vie c'est
difficile bon et toi tu fais des trous à
la chignole dans la barre et je suis
obligé à la fois de ramener pour qu'on
coule et que je suis obligé à la fois de
ramer et découper la flotte ah bon donc
c'était ça mon rôle mais vous allez
quand même plus loin puisque vous dites
ma mère sera vite partagée en parlant
toujours de cette collaboration pour les
Miss France sera vite partagée entre la
nécessité de m'avoir à ses côtés puisque
c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup plus
occupiez on va dire de la gestion et une
volonté étrange de m'écarter de son
chemin mais non pas du tout j'avais
cette idée là moi c'est midi c'est
l'impression qu'il avait mais c'est pas
du tout dans mon idée c'était la
conscience vraiment c'est inconscient de
votre part ou de ma part moi je suis
toujours très fier de Xavier c'est
peut-être qu'il a ressenti mais je n'ai
pas cherché en tous les cas cette
collaboration pourquoi elle était
difficile je sais pas peut-être parce
que ce ce rayonnement qu'elle a qu'elle
a toujours eu c'est vrai qu'il est pas
forcément facile de le partager aussi
vous êtes senti un peu dans l'ombre oui
un petit peu mais en fait
ensemble on a deux fortes personnalités
et Xavier plus forte apparemment
moi Xavier le fait pas c'est pas son
truc d'être dans la lumière
bonjour à tout le monde dans la rue par
tous les gens qui me parlent ça ne vient
pas trop ça Xavier mais par contre ce
qu'il a fait que Xavier j'aurais été
incapable de le faire oui la gestion un
Cup ah oui gestionnaire
c'est pas la notoriété encore une fois
moi le métal
c'est la reconnaissance du travail que
l'on fait donc c'est normal que de temps
en temps on l'explique un peu qui fait
quoi mais oui elle voudra que je voulais
pas savoir puisque tu me disais pas ce
que tu faisais c'est vrai que moi j'ai
découvert vraiment des choses que
j'imaginais même pas tous les
tractations qu'il a eu tous les
rencontres qu'il a eu avec toutes ces
directeurs de chaîne tous ces gens
passeraient un parcours du combattant
c'est vrai que
maintenant si ça paraît tellement
évident de voir avec ton Miss France
type sur une chaîne chaque année il faut
se souvenir ça a été compliqué j'étais
obligé de de d'attendre que le directeur
de sorte dans leur dans vouloir pour
pouvoir leur parler
était davantage reçu
je connaissais pas dire que la seule
fois où j'étais amené à TF1 tu as
demandé si Bouygues construire une
maison évidemment ça complique
France perdue retraite pour les miss un
peu compliqué j'adore parce qu'elle
voudrait reculer devant
une maison pour moi c'était dire une
chance de maison de Miss France avec un
lieu de rendez-vous de bureau de tout ça
quoi c'est une très bonne idée avec des
chants pour les bailleurs
il s'est demandé si c'était une
plaisanterie ou pas et
genevièvement faire découvrir alors
c'est à la fois drôle on pense là
maintenant mais c'est vrai que sur le
moment ça crisse un petit peu les
discussions et
un peu quand même oui
alors
quand vous racontez cela Xavier et quand
vous faites ce livre c'est pour montrer
justement ce que vous avez fait dans
l'ombre en fait quand on parle de
reconnaissance c'est ça c'est pour
montrer le travail effectué dans l'ombre
c'est Geneviève qui était dans la
lumière dans le fond c'est ça oui
c'était le chapeau qu'on voyait c'est
vrai si ça lui plaît
j'ai rien fait pour essayer de capter
j'ai capté comme ça par hasard et comme
ça mais j'ai pas couru derrière ça comme
ça alors ce qui est important de
rappeler c'est que c'est donc à 20 ans
vous vous entrez dans le comité en 61 et
son père et moi en 80 donc à 20 ans vous
arrivez dans ce comité et voilà il faut
faire le lundi et vendredi suivant je
dois présenter le gala sur scène à sa
place vous vous reprenez finalement la
charge de votre père et alors là vous
dites quelque chose de quand même de
très surprenant c'est que vous arrivez
alors c'est ce qui m'a le plus étonné
face à votre mère une femme que vous ne
connaissez pas oui
j'exagère un peu parce qu'il avait quand
même 20 ans il avait quand même vu
c'est vrai que on se connaissait pas
bien parce que j'avais jamais vécu avec
eux alors surprise donc dès l'âge de 6
mois bébé lorsque vous êtes malade vous
êtes élevé par votre père
on était des vrais sapins banque ce
qu'on appelle des certains banques on
vivait on n'avait pas d'argent
on gagnait trois fois rien donc les
enfants c'est vrai que ça une chaudière
à charbon
avec 4 degrés dans la maison coucher
avec nos manteaux fallait rallumer la
chaudière bon ça tombe n'a pas eu
d'enfant elle a été très frustrée de pas
avoir d'enfant et c'est sûr que Xavier
pour elle a été vraiment pour elle à une
chance et la maternité ça nous a pas
manqué de ne pas justement vraiment vous
occuper de l'éducation des enfants
j'étais tiraillé entre son père entre
tout ça trop à coeur sans recul et c'est
à dire suivez son père aveuglément nous
on partait on n'avait pas d'heure on
n'avait pas de jour enfin en fait vous
êtes une vraie artiste à dire que c'est
ce qui nous faisait vivre quand même
hein
est-ce que votre mère vous a manqué
votre mère votre père dans enfin oui
dans votre enfant parce que quand même
ça dure jusqu'à 16 ans j'ai pas eu ce
sentiment parce que justement j'ai eu un
autre foyer
aimant et qui m'entourait de tendresse
et d'affection donc j'ai pas ressenti ce
manque d'ailleurs je ne le raconte pas
de sous un nom
mais vous dites que du coup vous n'avez
pas une relation de mon fils que votre
vrai mère
à tout ce qui se passait ils ont été
voulu donc c'est pour ça que je dis
toujours à Xavier vous avez été les
enfants désiré mais est-ce que c'est
pour cela que ça a été difficile
finalement de vous retrouver à
travailler du jour puisque vous dites
vous-même je n'ai pas le souvenir que
que Geneviève avait regardé un bulletin
de notes durant ma scolarité ni fêter à
Noël un anniversaire et je dis
d'ailleurs je regardais même pas mon
bulletin à moi quand j'aimais d'ailleurs
que vous n'avez pas le réflexe de
l'appeler maman alors c'est vrai vous
l'avez d'ailleurs
pas longtemps je l'ai appelé madame
alors bien souvent alors bon père des
fois il lui arrivait de l'appeler comme
ça aussi parce que les petites à la
maison bon mais c'est vrai qu'en public
c'est pas facile parce que même quand là
je venant quand on a 40 ou 50 ans
appeler uniquement sa mère maman ça
passe pas facilement bon moi c'est
Madame c'est un petit peu comme
Philippe le frère de Louis XIV qu'on
appelait monsieur c'est bon c'est bon ou
monsieur
mais oui disons que je le prends comme
ça c'est
c'est une sorte de c'est respectueux
et aujourd'hui vous l'appelez toujours
madame non non non non
mais quand vous lui parlez non non
c'est maman c'est j'ai pas le réflexe je
ne crie d'ailleurs
et puis quand on se voit Sébastien voilà
vous évitez de la nommer oui une autre
chose que je me suis dit aussi c'est que
si vous n'aviez pas envie forcément de
pouponner de vous occuper des enfants
c'est que vous venez d'une très grande
famille Geneviève combien d'enfants dans
la famille 10 c'est ça 10 enfants dans
la famille est-ce que n'en aviez pas un
peu assez
moi dans l'aîné évidemment je m'occupais
beaucoup des petits je sais quand même
parce que c'est que des enfants
venir vous même merde
j'étais élevé dans une famille où ma
mère était une mère modèle on a eu des
parents formidables ici disons qu'on
vivait comme ça quoi au gré des vents je
voudrais d'ailleurs que l'on revienne
sur votre parcours si vous le voulez
bien Geneviève on regarde
est né d'une famille très nombreuse
Geneviève de Frontenay grandit à Longwy
dans une petite cité sidérurgique de
Lorraine où son père est ingénieur dans
cet univers austère est plutôt stricte
elle se distingue déjà tout jeune elle
avait pas les préjugés de sa classe
quand elle était dans son mentionnaire
elle y est pas restée longtemps non plus
parce que
les cernes n'est pas à vous comme on dit
mais c'est vrai que je voulais un petit
peu sortir de cet univers un peu triste
un peu un peu sombre et tout et que je
sais pas trop ce que je voulais faire
j'étaishéticienne j'étais un peu
mannequin et tout ça puis voilà mais
cette Fontenay est arrivé et puis j'ai
une belle vie grâce à lui
élue Miss Lorraine puis Miss élégance
elle rencontre en 1963 celui qui
deviendra le père de ses deux fils sans
jamais l'épouser Louis De Fontenay alors
président du comité Miss France alors il
fallait déjà de la part de mes parents à
ce sens large choix d'acceptation et
nous abondant dans les milieux des
centralesiens des Écoles des Mines et
des politiciens ça vous avez à l'hémis
la tête il faudra passer par des années
de vache maigre avant que le concours
connaisse son succès actuel grâce aux
émissions de télé négociées par le fils
Xavier de Fontenay Miss France Normandie
merci bravo à la première dauphine qui
est Miss
Rhône-Alpes
dès le début on était dur mon mari en 47
il faisait le sandwich il se baladait
avec une pancarte son ventre pour
annoncer l'élection de Miss Toulouse ou
je ne sais quoi parce qu'il y avait pas
d'argent pour faire des affiches
on a ramé beaucoup ramené
parce qu'on avait pas de confort du tout
du tout du tout et une famille
apparemment qui voyait pas forcément
d'un très bon œil
c'était quelque chose de qu'est-ce qu'on
va dire
que quand j'ai amené Louis De Fontenay à
Hagondange à ce moment-là on habitait à
gondance qu'il avait amené un bouquet de
roses et maman avait dit oh là là il y a
des épines sur ces roues c'est mauvais
présage et c'est vrai que votre mari au
début considérait que c'était une
gigantesque blague les miss ah bah il
est toujours
il a dit j'aurais pas gagné de l'argent
dans ma vie mais j'aurais bien rigolé
elle existe et c'est pour vous que c'est
devenu sérieux alors c'est devenu
une image donc il y a pas de raison
maintenant depuis la loi je reviens à
cela justement Geneviève on voit à quel
point vous étiez vous êtes une femme
libre donc les miss n'était pas sérieux
pour votre famille père ingénieur des
mines c'est sûr voilà deuxièmement vous
avez quand même deux enfants hors
mariage même si c'est avec le même homme
mais hors mariage vous êtes drôlement en
avance
pas justement sur les principes je
supporte un garde du tout
mais justement et alors petit à petit
vous devenez vous parce que après comme
je vous dis on a réussi au fil des
années à donner à cette image qu'on
pouvait considérer comme légère et sans
intérêt à donner justement
une image respectable et on a fait
quelque chose de sérieux de quelque
chose pas sérieux
et vous même est-ce que vous seriez
présenté vous voyez une élection de tout
oui
je savais pas quand j'étais abondant
oui moi je trouvais pas que j'avais le
style Miss France oui moi je suis pas
d'accord là dessus je pense que la miss
France si je ne le Fontenay c'est la
mise des Miss on le dit on dit toujours
chaque année mais je ne reste toujours
là mais des fois les gens veulent
Geneviève on s'en fout de mission et oui
donc voilà vous les avez supplantés vous
avez supplanté votre enfant et vous avez
souffert
au départ j'avais absolument pas d'idée
comme ça d'ailleurs dans un concours et
vous ce que je voudrais savoir à quel
moment vous avez compris que finalement
vous aviez une mine d'or entre les
puisque vous l'avez vendu
l'étape la plus importante c'est au
moment où cette mesure devient une
retransmission télévisée évidemment
pourquoi parce que ça tient les sponsors
pour organiser les élections après dans
des villes avec une émission on va dire
quelque chose de fleuriste
tellement bien passé que s'il a vendu et
le prix qu'il a vendu de l'ignore
d'ailleurs combien vous avez vendu
dans la presse 5 millions d'euros chacun
c'est un bon ordre de grandeur
mais ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
j'ai souvent entendu oui de toute façon
il a grâce à sa mère il vous rejette sa
mère bon moi quand mon père est mort je
l'écris dans le livre j'ai touché
l'équivalent de 500 euros j'ai démarré
avec effectivement une cuillère en
argent alors euh effectivement ce que
j'ai ce que j'ai réussi à bâtir je me
suis construit tout ça bon et en même
temps de se concentrer sur ça j'ai amené
aussi la notoriété de ma mère qui est
comme je le dis à café
Geneviève il vous a fallu beaucoup de
temps avant de comprendre qui était
votre fils de d'avoir de lui accorder
toute la confiance je comprends encore
davantage en ce moment grâce à ce livre
comment ça se livre vraiment
j'ai compris énormément de choses
vraiment et je le fais ici il dit de son
père et tout ah oui vraiment c'est vrai
alors Xavier vous dites en partant je
laisse donc à cette autre société un
cadeau une bombe à retardement
grenade des goupillé s'appelle Geneviève
de Fontenay
lui il va partir on va être
on la presse tout de suite et je suis
pas d'accord et ceci cela vous êtes à ce
point franchement je disais une arme de
destruction massive Geneviève ça peut se
produire oui qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
faire comme scandale genre tous les
scandales tout est possible on n'a pas
essayé un électron libre mais on n'a pas
essayé de vous virer pour l'instant pas
encore ça pour arriver mais vous
pourriez abandonner
qui seraient les emparés évidemment il y
a beaucoup de gens qui disent si je lui
avais plus là ce sera plus la même chose
ce sera plus Miss France ce sera ce sera
autre chose forcément
alors je voudrais maintenant que l'on
écoute un peu tout ce qui s'est passé
avec les miss c'est différent scandales
qui se sont quand même succédés ces
dernières années
on regarde et vous m'en parlez après
tous les deux
[Applaudissements]
2001 à peine élu Miss France une rumeur
se répand élodie Gossuin serait un homme
ça a vraiment mobilisé la France entière
tout le monde était choqué d'abord parce
que on estimait que c'était une injure
vis-à-vis d'Élodie l'annonce fait
l'effet d'une bombe télé radio journaux
tout le monde relais l'information
élodie Gossuin qui concourrait alors au
titre de Miss Univers est au cœur de la
tourmente
à ça c'est dur aussi de se défendre en
refusant aussi l'humiliation
quelques années plus tard ces Geneviève
de Fontenay qui est prise pour cible
Sophie alman Miss France 1998 dans un
livre n’épargne ni le mythe de la Miss
France ni sa présidente
et pour moi ça a été une des pires au
niveau physique silhouette on va vivre
pour l'élection de wizkalvados là-bas
vire tout le monde sait que c'est le
pays d'andouille bon ben même Michel
Drucker que originaire de là-bas a été
intronisé en double de Vire comme moi
alors ah non moi je sais pas comment
être remise en vue de vie pourquoi pas
miss boudin il y a quand même des
moments dans la vie on doit prendre ses
responsabilités c'est trop facile de
cracher dans la soupe comme ça
d'attaquer sans raison j'essayais au
cours de cette année de m'affirmer de
leur faire comprendre un petit peu parce
que je préférais mais bon c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça on est obligé de faire on
sait on a signé un contrat donc pendant
un an on suit quoi et des fois on peut
suivre bêtement entre guillemets les
prochaines scandaleuses sont Laetitia
Bléger Miss France 2004 et Valérie Bègue
Miss France 2008 photos dénudée volée au
détourné chacune apparaît dans des peaux
suggestives à la Une de magazines à
sensation car sans brutalement l'image
des Miss je me souviens j'avais fait la
couverture de l'Alsace du journal
L'Alsace avec écrit Laetitia Bléger la
honte de l'Alsace alors que il y avait
en même temps des profanations de
cimetière en Alsace et c'était moi la
honte de l'Alsace je réalise bien que
Playboy me suivra toute ma vie en fait
je le sais
la sanction tombe Laetitia Bléger sera
suspendu de son titre pendant 6 mois
quand à Valérie Bègue elle ne pourra pas
représenter la France au concours Miss
Monde des Miss Univers
mais vous me trouverez pas de photos de
moi à poil enfin la dauphine de Miss
France 2009 lui a intenté un procès pour
élection truquée la vie de Miss n'est
décidément pas un long fleuve tranquille
[Musique]
elle arrive TF1 elle a pris la place
d'une jeune journaliste qui avait fait
des études et qui présentait Téléfoot
elle arrive Miss France elle est
circuler il y a plus rien à voir elle
arrive sans lui sorte de Miss France un
an après elle va avec Laurent Fontaine
et Pascal Bataille un an après elle va
avec Jean-Pierre Pernaut un an combien
ça coûte lui jet privé les grands hôtels
et tout ça avec toujours Miss France
Antoine de fond bon elle ne restait pas
chez vous il y avait peut-être pas assez
de talent et là elle atterrit bah elle
est pas restée je confirme elle arrive
avec Lydia elle tombe son cheval
milliardaire de Christophe Soumillon qui
était qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire
alors je veux dire que quand je
l'entends
Miss France et tout mais elle s'en rend
pas compte que c'est les petits Miss
France ce serait pas loué là maintenant
avec de l'argent avec tout ce qu'il faut
elle était là derrière la gare de
Bar-le-Duc je vous assure que ça avouer
l'été c'est petit paga non je ne mets
pas qu'on puisse résonner cette façon et
Valérie Bègue alors elle est la menti
c'est important ça c'est grave
attendez c'est ce qui a modifié qu'elle
n'a pas été acceptée à Miss Univers
parce que les images à moitié nues sur
une croix aux États-Unis les images à
caractère sexuel et et
pornographiques c'est pas accepté je
sais mais jamais vous ne vous dites dans
votre fort intérieur oh finalement on ne
peut pas laisser la porte ouverte sinon
c'est fini c'est fini
dans ce monde où justement il y a plus
de retenue nulle part vous voyez les
lectures ce qu'avec les journaux c'est
toujours les filles il y a poil avec
leurs seins siliconés les fesses alerte
tout est à l'heure et ça ressemble plus
à rien
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi il y a de
plus en plus de scandales avec cette
recherche parce que c'est le scandale
agit comme un produit dopant et il fait
beaucoup plus parler que quand les les
choses vont bien
c'est vrai que
cette publicité elle est mauvaise parce
que une fois que la fois que cette
formidable bute est retombée avec la
tête il reste que le scandale à tel
point que cette année Chloé manteau est
revenu avec une écharpe de 5e dauphine
de Miss Univers personne n'en a parlé ça
intéresse personne non en revanche elle
va se déshabiller
la gardienne du temps oui mais enfin
elle est de plus en plus la prisonnière
de la tour je suis obligé de me battre
alors qui vous remplacera Geneviève
c'est une saga familiale alors il y a un
fils il y a aussi des petites filles
alors soit un lieu dans Miss France soit
elle prendra la tête de l'orientation
Miss France l'un ou l'autre
merci beaucoup à tous les deux
vous y ajouter quelque chose c'est un
véritable feuilleton
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Inna
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]